on dirait que le gène berg ancien
diplomate spécialiste de l'art bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous sur hd france
on l'a entendu vladimir poutine s'est
félicité de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
selon vous comment est-ce qu'elle a été
géré cette crise sanitaire en russie et
bien qu'il gérait je vais dire à la rue
c'est à dire le président enfin la russe
d'unia spécifiques
il a laissé une certaine latitude aux
gouverneurs de décider du type de
confinement de la période vu l'immensité
du pays 17 millions vu au fait que donc
il sait pas mis directement en avant il
a laissé les principaux responsables
surtout le maire de moscou qui s'est
vraiment illustré
c'est le premier qui a mis l'accent sur
l'importance des décisions à prendre et
qui a confiné moscou puisque la plupart
désaffectée dans la capitale du fait des
voyages et il a laissé au lieu de faire
une disposition comme ça a été le cas en
france où confinement général qu'ensuite
département vert orange et tout mais ça
à la fin mais dès le départ il a laissé
une certaine intitulé région vu
l'immensité il ya les foyers n'étaient
pas aussi vivent partout en russie
on traite pas le cocasse contre est
libéré on traite pas normal ce que
montre est sotchi et lassitude mal un
petit peu la philosophie alors beaucoup
de commentateurs hongrie ont remis en
cause avait incité les chiffres là aussi
je crois que chan trahir kick ce choix
les russes ont d'emblée dit que leurs
statistiques
il ne relevait les morts du cornât virus
que ceux qui n'avaient que ça lorsqu'il
ya une autre maladie une pathologie eh
bien on déclarait plutôt cette
pathologie comme l'arrêt cardiaque ou
autre chose rare alors est ce que c'est
une manipulation des chiffres
c'est une manière de présenter
différentes mais en tout cas ils ne sont
pas caché qu'ils allaient dès le début
au cdh yeux des comptages de cette façon
a alors fait venir poutine s'est
notamment penché sur la question de la
relance de l'économie dans quelle
situation économique se trouve la russie
aujourd'hui au sortir de cette crise
sanitaire pas écouté l
le problème c'est que elle combine le
coût de la crise sanitaire comme chez
nous et le décrochage très fort qui est
lié à la crise sanitaire mais pas
uniquement
on peut pas rentrer maintenant là peu de
temps dans le la négociation entre ryad
et moscou sur le match sur la baisse de
la production
donc il ya eu un très fort décrochage du
prix du pétrole mais qui affectait
beaucoup de pays pétroliers et donc la
russie a vu non seulement le tourisme
s'arrêter mais évidemment une perte fort
et j'ajoute c'est moins connu
les prix du gard assez encore décrocher
de plus en plus sans vous donner un
chiffre
le million b2b t u qui est qui sert de
référence
il ya quelques années était 12 dollars
le million et maintenant il est tombé à
2 en asie donc la russie a reçu ce choc
qui est ici un peu supérieur à la
récession qu'elle a connue en 2009 en
2009 c'est 7,9
là elle va connaître noir 9 - 8 - 9
s'appelle la france
bonsoir oui tina sur l'animé poutine a
annoncé des mesures notamment celle
d'une hausse de l'impôt sur le revenu
cet impôt unique sur le revenu je le
rappelle a été introduit en 2001 c'était
d'ailleurs l'une des réformes clés du
premier mandat de la dmr poutine est
certain aujourd'hui évoque un premier
coup de canif au taux d'imposition
uniforme
le sujet est délicat aujourd'hui oui
parce que je me souviens tout inédite
donc tant que je serai au pouvoir je ne
changerai pas d'impôt sur le revenu
j'ai été élu avec un simple à type
d'impôt et je ne change pas mais ça
c'était dans l'île au moment où il
faisait beau maintenant gilles aura
alors je peux amener une précision pas
pour le correspondant je fais le petit
calcul il passe le tout et écouter
regarder les taux qu'on a marginaux en
russie 13-6 extrêmement bas il ne passe
à 15
pour tous les revenus supérieurs à
samedi en double j'ai fait un petit
calcul rapide chez 65000 euros par an ce
qui correspond à 5000 euros par unité de
consommation est pratiquement en france
on considère qu'on est riche à ce niveau
là alors comme enrichi niveau le plus
bas
samedi enrichir on est beaucoup plus
riche qu'on est en france donc c'est
cette imposition frappe vraiment les
tueries alors il ya d'autres mesures
intéressant par exemple en quelqu'un
voudra biffle et comment en quelques
mots s'il vous plaît malheureusement la
lisons des n'est pas très bonne je vous
écoute un instant non alors par exemple
il va baisser l'âge de l'auto
entrepreneur de 17 à 16 ans il va pêcher
il va il ouvre à fond de saut milliards
de roubles pour accorder des traits 2%
compte tenu de la fin du coup le crédit
actuelle riche et c'est vraiment très
intéressant des crédits mobiliers des
crédits famille lyon et surtout de
débureaucratiser plus le secteur de la
construction
il a montré que certains hôpitaux ont
été construites très vite et et dernier
élément qui est très intéressant il veut
développer le haïti la technologie bon à
distance mais russes sont très forts ce
moment ils ont bien d'aix ils ont comme
des cerveaux des mathématiciens et donc
ils vont vraiment sortir du pétrole et
du gaz en mettant l'accent sur ces
technologies nouvelles et là c'est que
c'était ses raisons et c'est intéressant
parce que là il a mis plusieurs fois
l'accent sur ce côté novateur de
l'économie russe merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions pardon pour cette liaison un
peu difficile eugène berryer je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien diplomate
spécialiste de la russie